Have you ever read an article about sexism in the media and then made the
horrible mistake of scrolling down into the comment section because if you have
then you've seen someone trying to derail that conversation with demands of what
about the men.
Now the last thing the guys who are making that demand really want to do is have
a serious discussion about the sometimes harmful ways that media represents
masculinity and they especially don't want to have that conversation if it's
inspired by feminism and so that's exactly what this project is going to
welcome to the pop culture detective agency,
a brand new web series that looks like media through a critical lens with a
special emphasis on the depictions of men and masculinity in popular culture.
Hi there.
I'm Jonathan.
I'm a pop culture critic and a video producer.
I've been making online videos about social and political issues for over a
decade now.
You may have seen some of my work a while back.
I made a viral video called Buffy versus Edward.
Get Out.
I like watching you sleep,
so
just kind of oil a drop you out head first.
I just want to try one thing
and then later another one called Donald duck meets Glenn Beck,
Jana job,
lazy slob that refuses to get off the couch and get a job.
That remix made one of these two cartoon characters very,
very unhappy.
We're looking into the funding of this gentleman and the incredible propaganda
against me like you've never seen using Disney and Disney cartoons
over the past three years.
I've had the honor of working as producer and Co writer on the first season of
feminist frequency is influential web series tropes versus women in video games.
Both of them is male character and the smurfette principle have been normalized
in gaming and a mass media more broadly,
so much so that the two tropes usually pass under the radar and are often
reproduced.
I unconsciously
today I'm excited to build on that work with a brand new series.
This one we'll focus on deconstructing the representations of masculinity that
we see embedded in movies,
TV shows,
comic books and Video Games.
The messages that pop culture sends to boys and men about masculinity are
consistently both limiting and harmful.
At this point,
we're all familiar with the standard media conventions.
Men are typically shown as either stoic heroes who use violence to solve all of
their problems or as bumbling fools who are incapable of nurturing or caregiving
with all the conflicting media messages out there.
It's not surprising that a lot of young men are very about what it means to be a
real man.
In the near future.
I'll be looking at how manhood is framed by the jet I order in George Lucas's
six star wars films.
You'll insights as well,
no feelings.
Deep down
they knew you credit,
but they could be made
and then later I'll be investigating some of the harmful ideas about geek
masculinity that we find on the Big Bang theory.
I'm sorry,
what universe is wonder woman blonde.
Relax.
No one's going to be looking at her hair.
Yeah,
there is a lot to talk about right there,
but this project won't only focus on the negative.
I'll also be producing a series of videos that look at positive examples of
manhood in the media.
The first of those positive episodes explores emotional expression on the
cartoon network series.
Steven universe.
You understand?
Yeah.
Okay.
Just be careful.
Oh,
I'm going to run fresh out of family,
stay with everyone and keep them safe.
A little further down the line.
I'll also be looking at the remarkable way is that empathy and also fatherhood
are represented on that show.
These episodes will be a long form video essays between 10 and 20 minutes long.
That longer format really allows me the opportunity to delve into how culture is
impacted by media and vice versa,
how media is impacted by culture.
I'll also be making some shorter videos to supplement the longer ones.
Some of those will be debunking sexist myths and others will be defining
commonly misunderstood terms.
You can also look forward to some fun super cuts that highlight various patterns
in the media.
Although masculinity will be the primary focus of this series.
From time to time I'll be creating visual essays about other sociopolitical
issues related to popular culture.
You can see examples of all that stuff.
Overall,
my youtube channel and also in my patrion page now there are more than a few
youtube channels that claim to be concerned about men.
Unfortunately,
most of them are aggressively antifeminist and they just spend their time
scapegoating and blaming women for everything.
It is a really bad scene.
My new channel will be an alternative to that growing trend.
The critical analysis that I'll be using is very much inspired by feminist
theory.
It's through that lens that I'll be looking at the ways that boys and men are
harmed as a byproduct of hypermasculinity.
So my hope is that this video series can help open up conversations about how we
as men can work together to achieve more constructive,
cooperative and empathetic forms of masculinity and this is where you come in.
I'm going to need your support to help keep this project going.
Creating these videos really is a full time job.
They take a tremendous amount of time to research,
write and produce,
especially for just one person.
There'll be no ads on anything I make.
Plus all my videos will be available for free for everyone,
including so the only way this project can continue is if you find it,
you'll find all the details in the text below this video.
I am super excited for this project and I hope you are too,
so please become a patron of the pop culture detective agency.
Yeah.
I just promised to watch both the star wars prequels and did the Big Bang
theory.
That's going to be worth some support right there,
because that's going to be excruciating.